we're looking at the complex how'd you
get root beer I hope you remember this
from last year when we're doing public
summers it was one of the cooler salts
with took advantage um because we're
looking like a diagram in the roots of
unity do you remember that was a gimme
um here are the first while I ask it's
seven weddings one person boring but
these are the the next four of the
integer roots of unity right so these
are the square roots of unity the cube
roots of unity the fourth roots and the
fifth roots of unity and I hope these
diagrams you about now if we given when
we look at these we thought hey that's
kind of it there's all kinds of
geoengineering patents here that mustn't
be a coincidence
another coincidence and the thing I
wanted to point out was every time you
have a look at with me up with the odd
Palace it's a little more obvious but
when the even Palace is still the same
every time you have roots of unity you
notice that the roots come in conjugate
pairs do you notice that that's what
this some tears is named dr. right so
for example via the cube roots of unity
what he got here are these guys these
are going to be this angle here is what
to apply on three I think it's you my
ring so this is close to Planet three
plus I sine C Python three remember but
that's one of these and then down here
you've got cause off - dude - three I
sine of minus 2 PI over 3 and that's
what brings it underneath because of
course cosine which gives you the
horizontal it's an even function so when
you put in minus two five three you line
up vertically but sine is an odd
function so when you pretty it flips you
over the other side okay and you notice
the same thing with the fifth roots of
unity
you've got z1 or stars in two and then
five next up and he got sent three and
then four they're not chopped and of
course you know in these two instance to
see where you've got even powers it's
less interesting because when you've got
those real roots
you notice what one are they of what
other river it's you they're actually
real numbers for the square roots of one
they want a negative one every real
number because it has no imaginary pot
every real number is its own complex
conjugate remember that because a kludge
again is x plus iy aggressive X minus I
1 well if you've come to know by then
the country gives you back act now
well did that last you we did not prove
it we did not prove this we just noticed
it we saw is kind of cool ok today now
we're back in polynomial man we have the
tools to prove this and for such a
profound result it has a very strong and
elegant proof so rather just looking
specifically at writs of duty
I'm never going to consider any
polynomial serve on that is this is
where the complex would you derivative
apply so what does the coefficients are
real that's really important okay and
you'll see it it comes up in a second so
let's let's give this polynomial some
terms it's gonna have probably a
constant term so I'm going to call that
a not it's gonna have an X term I'll
call that a 1 K X and so on oops sorry
Jimmie's it's still in real McCoy
and this is a polynomial what I need for
the series so even though I'm used to
writing about we go forever
this is polynomial and it hasn't in a.m.
okay which in facts about me so what
I've got here is any polynomial but
remember I specified I want these
coefficients you can reuse okay so I
better say that it's going to be
actually very critical to my career so
everything I'm gonna because you're
going to much well I will signify the 8
or a 1 a 2 etcetera all of them all the
way up to a n they're all real numbers
ok all right now what I want to imagine
is I know one of the roots okay because
I don't even know what's polynomial is
it made it up it has no value anything I
thought no way this but if I have a root
and I'll give it a name and what can you
say
because that is one of my variables I'm
going to use eye makeup okay so I'm
gonna say if Omega is a root
okay 5f ignition what our route means is
that your policy through to the corner
axis right so all of this is going to
evaluate our to zero when it when a
substitute in omega so in my language
here like my function notation I'm gonna
say P or beta is equal to zero okay so
what does this look like well it's just
going to look like this exact line
except instead a sense I'm gonna have a
baby and instead of that on the left
hand side I'm going to have zero
okay and just for continues I'm gonna
write the 0 the right hand side we tend
to do that with general forms so one cut
here is a dot plus any one begun this is
an actual number now another variable
plus a2 Omega Square and so on all the
way up to that where they get to the
intern what do I evaluate that that's
the wall equal to zero okay nothing
dramatic so far I'm just kind of laying
stage now remember that this theorem is
about complex conjugates right so what
I'm sort of suggesting is I guess the
declarative I may not there may be
father right that must be a root of this
right so that's kind of what I'm trying
to prove I've got to bring the
conjugates in somehow
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take remember this is a big complex
number down right like but maybe it's an
apple in Melbourne so if I knew what I
think it was I could expand this all out
if I had a death wish
okay so this is just one number in here
just in long example I'm going to take
the conjugate of the whole number right
the conjugate of everything over here on
the left that is
NASA since I've taken because you get
off the term on the left I've been a
technical engineer officer on the right
now I'm gonna pause here for a moment
and I'm going to write a couple of
things off on the side here that will be
important for us to understand but I
don't look into cloud how they line up
with the first thing I want to notice is
what happens when you take the conjugate
of a sum of complex numbers okay let's
say just for time you can say let's
think about like some Zed okay let's
call it X plus iy the importance country
at set bar is going to be okay
I need another clinic another complex
number Rana so I can see what happens
when I add them so let's have been
begging down let me call it a plus IB
that's just this common what would if I
make a mommy okay good so now what
happens if I take this thing right then
plus my makeup and do the conjugate of
the whole line what will actually happen
and the answer is I say well I'm gonna
first add the two numbers together
that's X plus iy plus a plus B yeah and
I'm gonna take the conjugate of a lot
but I know what to do this but you can
take the imaginary parts I'm going to
change the sign does that make sense so
this is going to become X minus iy is
that nothing happens back that's real
and these become minus 5/8 out okay now
look what am I got here
that's just zipper and the thing about
do you agree with that so what I'm
saying is the conjugate of a sum is the
same as the sum of the conjugates is
that okay so that's not like it's just
addition agree that's always happening
the second piece I need to know is what
I mentioned over here right which is if
you've got a real number
in other words it has no imaginary part
then it's complex conjugate is itself
that okay I need those two pieces of
information and watch what happens to
this life okay first I said the
conjugate of a sum is the sum of the
conjugates so I'm going to do each one
individually now so I've got a knot
I've got a wanna make up this time
bunch of my new team like but we just
said we just stated that every real
number not a whole lot of them ever
you're a little when I take its
conjugant
it's just gonna be itself right so if
it's the easiest one have you done
anything why don't you wipe is because
unit 0 of course is zero
angel is a real number so it's conjugate
will be a dork and I can do that for
every single real number that I have
written this will be a 1 times Omega bar
right like this is a complex number so
it will actually have a proper code you
do write distinct country I should say
this is going to be a to
Chimaera plus the thud sorry thank you
okay now look at what we have John
written justice pelvic familiar right
this is bull this than one of the first
things I wrote down this is this line
but instead of a minute everything is
doing to make it boss right
what does that mean when it is start
line what did it come from
it came from the fact that they're timid
right we stated this because I'm new as
a factor but but wonderfully thinking
about the fact of it is that it's
converse is true right if you can like
this is the whole reason this is why we
use the positive to fight in fact it so
I can evaluate it for a big bar and I
get zero that means that like what this
is saying is P of Omega bar is zero
therefore Omega bar is original it's so
simple and yet it's the real rigorous
proof behind all this cool geometry
which we kind of just thought well
that's kind of nice okay but here like
this in a very very small number of
lines
it proves it's very important for you
okay you're gonna use it a lot in excess
throughput you the cop expose you get
root there is a cute I Taylor because as
soon as you find life experience you
found the other half right so long as
the coefficients are real so you don't
need to go you know what's what you
found these two we're done you know
there are going to be exactly five you
find one two three
I've gone past halfway the remaining
ones must be conjugates of the ones I
already have that makes it